let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome
good afternoon happy happy happy hump
day
it's wednesday
three o'clock central
four o'clock eastern and you know what
the [ __ ] that means
we are live
youtube twitter twitch
and boy do we have a show for you today
today is the very the very last show
of 2021 the very last podcast now you
know we do the [ __ ] list roundup every
single weekday noon eastern 11 central
on twitch and twitter
but this is the last podcast
and we have a very special guest that we
talked to today we we actually recorded
this
um
before the christmas break
we were trying to get everything
recorded with the holidays to keep the
podcast going
but we have a special guest today
he's the democratic candidate for
congress and washington's third
brent henrich is on our show today
it's a very very good long interview we
actually don't play trivia because we
didn't have the scheduling to where we
have someone else so i apologize that we
don't have trivia today i i we're gonna
have to have brent back on just to play
trivia maybe we'll bring him on one day
just to play trivia with us
just so he gets a chance because i i'm
very disappointed that we didn't get a
chance to play
trivia but we had more time to talk
about washington's third because he
really breaks down
what washington's third is it gives us a
good idea of like how big it is
uh
the land diversity like you know there's
oceanfront and there's farmland and
agricultural land and so he goes through
what washington's third is
and then he kind of breaks down who he's
running against
and he also talks about um
a hobby of his legos so we go through
the legos as well
with brent so stay stay tuned for the
full two hours
today to hear
everything that brent has to say it's
very important
uh not just to washington's third but
all around the country we have to have
uh these democrats
amplified
beating the drum
pro democracy
just keep saying those words that's how
it works
that's how it works that's how messaging
works
that's how pro-democracy is going to
work
i'm going to play into some dumbass here
in just a second
because there's
there's something trending on twitter
that i just i can't help but rant about
today i just am not going to be able to
[ __ ] help myself
i don't think i'll be able to contain
that there's a certain someone
certain someone who may have a hoof foot
who wants a divorce
well
i'm gonna lay that [ __ ] [ __ ] out
right right now right here on the
podcast
i haven't tweeted about it yet
other other than this broadcast that's
the only thing i've tweeted about the
national divorce
that a certain someone wants
and i'm gonna tell you the code words
that they're trying to use this is let's
go brandon type [ __ ] right this national
divorce thing whatever the [ __ ] they're
talking about here this is a let's go
brandon thing
[ __ ] joe biden let's go brandon national
national divorce civil war
white privilege
we want all white privilege
so the [ __ ] it is come on
so we're going to run down through that
with twitter and we're also going to
talk to brent we might we might
it's possible we'll have gabe join us
from a cell phone gabe gabe you normally
joins us on the podcast the executive
producer gabe sanchez but he is
traveling today
um for the holidays so we weren't able
to make the timing happen it just it
happens sometimes it [ __ ] happens
what are you gonna do
but we're still here we're still live
we're still going we're still kicking we
ain't gonna quit no matter the holiday
and we're gonna keep going through the
holiday on this next one you know we
took a few days off of the [ __ ] list
roundup for for the christmas holiday
but the new year's holiday we are not
gonna let down
all the way through friday and back on
monday noon eastern 11 central twitch
and and twitter so make sure that you're
following uh the shitless roundup follow
us on twitch download the twitch app app
if you want you can also watch it on
twitter
and then i go i go over and i put the
you know the the
the vod the video on demand the
recording of it
i put it over on on youtube
so make sure make sure you subscribe to
the youtube channel so you don't miss
any of that you also don't miss the
bonehead of the week
that's important stuff too you guys know
we do like this weekend show we do all
kinds of shows here we do the podcast we
do the [ __ ] list roundup we do the bone
end of the week
content content content because we're
pounding the drum the pro democracy drum
and we're going to continue to pound it
today
when i go uh
when i decide
exactly when i'm going to strike
and give our rebuttal to the national
divorce
they want a divorce
oh they they they just can't help but
they're [ __ ] code word [ __ ]
oh this
let's go brandon oh [ __ ]
all right
we'll be right back with with with the
divorce settlement
don't just stay with us right after
these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
hello and welcome to a dramatic reading
of text messages sent to mark meadows on
january 6th can he make a statement
ask people to leave the capitol
fox news host sean hannity please get
him on tv
destroying everything you have
accomplished
fox news host brian kilmeade mark the
president needs to tell people in the
capitol to go home
this is hurting all of us he is
destroying his legacy
fox news host laura ingram he's got to
condemn this [ __ ] asap
the capital police tweet is not enough
we need an oval office address
he has to lead now
it has gone too far and gotten out of
hand
donald trump jr and this has been a
dramatic reading of text messages sent
to mark meadows on january 6.
[Music]
[ __ ] em
[ __ ] up welcome
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome welcome back
thanks for staying with us i guess gabe
is kind of on the podcast today
this little videos and commercials that
we do during the commercial breaks i
know everyone likes those things that's
one reason why we take commercial breaks
and to get all the tech you know ready
and going make sure we're staying up to
speed
so let's get into
the divorce settlement here
because apparently someone wants a
national divorce i want to get a divorce
so right now let's let's go uh let's see
let's let's go to this screen screen
here there we go
let's see it is that number oh well
let's just refresh here
it looks like national divorce is at
number five it wasn't number four so
she's falling back marjorie taylor
greene obviously is the one who's
trending with this
national divorce marjorie taylor green
suggests a national divorce scenario
after chronicles magazine associate
editor
pedro l gonzalez says he supports
actively discriminating against any
transplants from liberal states
and what they're talking about here here
is as if a bunch a bunch of people are
up and moving
um from liberal states to red states
uh which i mean maybe possible you know
maybe they are congregating to red
states a lot of these blue states are
not having some of this nonsense
um when they're talking about public
safety and public health and a lot of
these people are so [ __ ] dead set on
getting people sick
and make their making their communities
unsafe that they're willing to move to
other communities to make them unsafe
you follow what's happening here like
like
like they're saying segregation like you
can't if that's the case you're kind of
aren't you kind of segregate whatever
you know
maybe maybe it's not even that because i
believe some of the movement around
states may have nothing to do with red
blue democrat liberal
a lot of it has to do with
where the jobs are where the jobs are
going
it's a workers economy there's now
hiring signs everywhere
labor is in high demand right there's
not a shortage of labor it's in high
demand
and that gives people mobility which is
good we're not there yet like we're not
to the economy that we need for workers
in the middle class yet
we're probably a long way off
but we're headed in the right direction
with this economy for goddamn sure
not in the wrong direction
but it sounds like pedro here is
suggesting
that we should act when he's saying it
and that's the quote actively
discriminate
so here we are with this [ __ ] gqp
these dumb [ __ ] yelling and
screaming about whoppers and cheesecake
and applebee's
the battle of applebees
wanting a civil war because that's i
mean that's really i mean it's not even
everyone keeps saying civil war they
want to race war people
that's the civil war that they want they
want to race war
and this is always the [ __ ] neo-nazis
wet dream in this country
is to have a race war
right
that was a whole thing what do you think
this is
and this is all [ __ ] code as well
it's code talk just like let's go
brandon you [ __ ] can't even say [ __ ]
joe biden
a bunch of goddamn [ __ ]
but that's what it is it's [ __ ] code
talk
it's code talk
national divorce scenario
let's go to the [ __ ]
the thread here i want to show you let's
let's let's make this thread a little
bigger
oh maybe not there we go
okay i'm trying to get my new controls
you know we got some new controls here
thanks to everyone um pitching in on the
podcast
upgrade fun thank you very much all you
folks out there
oh
yep
ah let's see
minus touch had a pretty good take let's
go to their take here
national divorce is gtp code for
secession and civil war it definitely is
code talk
yeah let's move this so we can see this
whole [ __ ] thing
yeah
it's definitely [ __ ] code talk
for sure
and the code talk is
that we
don't want
you to vote because if you vote you will
win
and if you will win there will be
equality and diversity and we don't want
that
we want our white privilege and we're
going to use white grievance national
divorce
to get it
what is being perpetuated here
is that they know they're [ __ ]
terrified that even their voter
suppression plans even their [ __ ]
gross ass gerrymandering
with their bogus ass [ __ ] senses that
they did
and that they rigged up
and now they're rigging districts to try
to win because they can't win otherwise
rand paul even said if we count their
votes it's stealing the election if
democrats vote
and we count their votes they've stole
the election
rand paul said he agreed with the
american conservative
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
marjorie taylor green is taking it one
step further from what rand paul and the
american conservative was saying
what she's saying is is we only want the
states
that we want to count to count that's it
they can't divorce nationally that's
[ __ ] dumb can you imagine if the red
states went without federal funding how
[ __ ] they would be
completely 100 percent [ __ ] hundo
percent oh [ __ ]
they can't do without federal funding
they can't 22 of all federal funding
comes from california and [ __ ] new
york alone
then what would they do
then how would they hide behind their
thin veil of of conservatism
and
and talk about oh shingle issues like
abortion because we care about abortion
what we really want to do is perpetuate
fascism
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
national divorce with margie taylor
green is only one step further than what
rand paul was talking about that
democrats shouldn't have their votes
counted
not only do they not want democrats to
be able to register and canvas voters
they don't want democrats to count votes
they don't want democrat votes to be
counted
she's taking it one step further to say
that
that
blue states in her mind blue states
don't get to count at all they don't
even get to vote
it's fascism folks
they're not hiding it
they're terrified they're
scared this is all desperation is what
this is
from rand paul from marjory taylor green
from all these republican legislators
desperately trying
desperately trying to rig up the vote
because they know what's going to happen
because we keep pounding the drum
we keep pounding the drum of the big
bird bill we keep pounding the drum
a voting rights can you imagine
how how [ __ ]
how
defeated they will be
if we get any kind of voting rights bill
codified
imagine it
their victory over roe v wade almost
won't be worth it to them which that in
of itself is another [ __ ] discussion
because that's part of their national
divorce as well
that's why they're going to states like
mississippi and texas and taking away
pregnant people's liberty over their
[ __ ] bodies
they don't want democracy
they're they're authoritarians
they're fascist
they want a fascist state
if you're going to vote for a democrat
they don't want you to vote
not only they not want you to vote they
don't want your vote to count
and they don't even want your state to
count they want all your money
let's let's leave let's be clear on that
they definitely definitely
want all your [ __ ] money
all of it the whole [ __ ] caboodle they
want all the tax dollars
how else are their states going to
survive how are they going to build
highways how are they going to pay for
healthcare
for all their impoverished people that
they've impoverished with their thin
belt conservatism all these years
by taking away people's education by
taking away people's health care
by taking away their
their economic mobility
by not giving them shots
inside the economy
regardless rule
urban black white
their goal is always to divide that's
always that's their [ __ ] that's always
their [ __ ] goal and it's always we've
known this because they say that's what
democrats do that's what pro-democracy
they want to divide us up it's all
projection
all of it
and this code word projection here with
national divorce because they know their
that their ideas [ __ ] suck
and they know that we know that their
ideas
[ __ ] suck
and the only way to keep perpetuating
their ideas
is to continue to brainwash people
on facebook and social media into giving
them money
so that way they can perpetuate this
idea that democrats and try to institute
inside of our institutions whether it be
the supreme court whether it be the
national census rather it be
gerrymandered district inside the states
that the legislators the republican
legislators are going to do take away
polling places
if you're pro-democracy out there and
here's what i mean by that we keep
throwing these words around but this is
the war we're fighting
this is it
and you have to fight the war that
you're in not the war you want to be in
or the war you're going to be in you
have to fight the war you're in
this is a war for our democracy
and they are ready
to have a national divorce meaning
democrats don't count you know what the
next step is after national divorce
we've seen it before in fascist regimes
our guest today
brent henrich is running
against a q a on her a [ __ ] maggot a
crazy steep and in trader tv
type
always on there with marjorie taylor
greene matt gatz is always supporting
him
and it's the same nonsense they keep
talking about donald trump being speaker
of the house
you don't think that's the next step in
the national divorce
just say it just say fourth reich
already just say it you [ __ ]
say fourth reich that's what you mean
marjorie taylor green that's what you
mean matt gatz that's what you mean
steve bannon
they kept talking about trump's gonna
come back on march 4th and september
89th and they kept moving the goal post
kept moving the goal post and they keep
moving the goal post
they couldn't get him in before the end
of this year
which again was [ __ ] absolutely
delusional
it was never going to happen
there was never a situation where
somehow joe biden was gonna be escorted
out of the white house and donald trump
was gonna be entered into the white
house
[ __ ] bonkers there's about as much
chance of that as jfk
[ __ ] out is himself in dallas texas
bone-headed type [ __ ] from bone-headed
tight people
but their plan folks
is to make it a fascist state and do a
coup
and do it inside the government the last
coup they tried to overthrow the
government right
by sending their little minions that are
now getting sentenced to two years four
years five years
these [ __ ] boneheads that were duped
into thinking that donald trump was
gonna save them or whatever the [ __ ]
they thought you know whatever
delusional [ __ ] they believed on
facebook or telegram or where the [ __ ]
they were reading it
and then whatever the [ __ ] was told to
them and organized and planned with them
we're gonna find that out soon enough
i have a feeling
there's 725 people i think is the
approximate number now indicted
federally indicted for january 6 by the
department of justice
there's been handfuls of them sentenced
to years in prison by the department of
justice which is ran by meyer garland
the attorney general of the united
states
this is little fish big fish stuff
and these people like marjorie taylor
green steve bannon matt gatz joe kent
talking about a national divorce rand
paul talking about we can't count
democrats votes because that's stealing
an election
all of that
all of that
the whole [ __ ] and caboodle
is their plan for a coup
all of it
they want to take the house of
representatives they see that as their
striking point
they've all they they don't even project
it they say it
matt gatz joe kent margie tay the green
steve bannon
they say it out loud
they say it out loud
that they want
to take the house so they can make
donald trump speaker now donald trump
isn't going to be speaker if they take
the house
that's all that's that's all duping
they're duping the trump voters
because they don't they think the trump
voters are stupid
they think they're [ __ ] dumb
which you you draw your own conclusion
there
but their plan is to install someone
like marjory taylor green miss national
divorce here matt gatz jim jordan
andy biggs
mo brooks
steve bannon
michael flynn
they want to install a nazi into the
speaker of the house someone who is
willing to to do whatever the [ __ ] they
want whenever they want no guard rails
doesn't matter what the law is doesn't
matter what the constitution says they
want the speaker of the house
to i don't know it's delusional
but to remove biden and kamala harris
all at the same time and crown
themselves king
because they read the constitution and
they see the speaker of the house is
third in line
and they start having wet dreams
about how they can install a dictator i
mean this is what fascists do they sit
around a table and have wet dreams about
how to install an authoritarian dictator
that's what this national divorce [ __ ]
is about
that's what she's
saying is she doesn't want democrats to
vote she doesn't want democrats who do
vote their votes to count and not only
that she doesn't want what she considers
blue states
to even have elections
and be part of the national election
because folks if they have their
national divorce where the blue states
and the red states get divorced and the
blue states don't count
what do you think the congress looks
like
you think there's democrats in the
congress
if there's no blue states
how many democrats you think are going
to be in congress what do you think what
do you think the majority is going to be
who do you think is going to be the
speaker of the house
that's what she's saying is we need to
make it to where blue states
can't vote
that way that way we can only have
republicans
in the house of representatives in the
senate
that way we can crown the king that we
want
whether it be donald trump steve bannon
whoever the [ __ ] it is it doesn't matter
who it is it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter they they they use
donald trump to get all his dumb [ __ ]
toothless idiots out there who wear maga
hats still who still think he won he won
oh he won by 8 million
facebook says so
my uncle ned on facebook told me that
joe biden lost
i heard that he shits his pants
no no trump shits his pants and he's
[ __ ] his pants marjorie taylor green
is [ __ ] her pants lauren bobert matt
gatz jim jordan mo brooks andy biggs
you're on you're on alert
and the reason why you're on alert is
because the january 6 select committee
is on your [ __ ] heels
and when the january 6 select committee
is on your heels that means a big list
of expulsions
that means a big list of criminal
referrals
for anyone who did anything that might
look like sedition possible treason
and if you don't think that that's
happening if you think oh well the
democrats are just you know they're
they're not playing hardball and oh
they're not good they're just gonna let
everybody buy with this why are they
[ __ ] freaking out
why are they freaking out about their
phone records why are they freaking out
about any kind of elections anywhere
they don't want elections because they
know if there's free and fair elections
they lose
they know they don't have power
and a fascist not in power
can't create a fascist state
they can't and that's up to us the
pro-democracy people that's where we
come in that's where you come in that's
where brent comes in that's where all
these democratic candidates and all
these districts come in
is the pro democracy candidates
are pro-democracy
so let's have a pro-democracy government
not a fascist state
this [ __ ] code word national divorce
just say it fourth reich i don't know
tweet it hashtag fourth reich that's
what she's talking about here
fourth reich
is what she means by national divorce
that's what she means
she wants a fascist state one step
further than what rand paul wait wait
till next week or the week after because
these public hearings are going to start
the text messages are going to start to
roll out again
we're going to start seeing who's what
and who is where who is talking to who
we're going gonna start to see some of
that [ __ ] not all of it because a lot of
it was criminal i'm sure
and the criminal parts are gonna be
referred to department of justice to
handle in a grand jury
not in the open
in a public hearing
so be prepared to be patient as well
because they're not going to talk about
criminality right out in the open that's
going to that's going to
really damage any kind of criminal
investigation and especially a criminal
indictment that they can get from a
grand jury on some of these seditious
actors
rather it be how they were raising funds
or how they were obstructing congress
either way
so be prepared
to be patient i know it [ __ ] sucks
but we have to have patience here it's
working trust me
they didn't indict 725 people for
nothing
they had they haven't been giving out
four year sentences for nothing
those are the little fish folks
the little fish are getting four years
in a federal prison
four years
and federal time isn't like state time
where you do like half of it or a third
of it
you do the whole [ __ ]
the whole [ __ ]
federal
time that's right
and obstruction charges
15 20 years for those son of a [ __ ]
sedition 15 20 years for those son of a
[ __ ]
and you wonder why they keep talking
about
overtaking the government and committing
a coup you're still wondering why
january 6th
steve bannon roger stone
mike flynn were pardoned
you don't think that there was a trade
give me a [ __ ] break get the [ __ ] out
of here with that [ __ ]
stay right here we'll be right back with
the interview with brent
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered part and blanket
specifically works to make you feel safe
and cozy after your involvement on
january 6th and if you're one of the
other members of congress who also
helped with the attempted coup pardon
blanket will protect you too hard and
blanket is made of a sort of soft fleece
and a layer of sheep's wool and they're
a hundred percent made in the usa don't
delay and get your pardon blanket today
for just 99.99
actual parting's not guaranteed
the tony michaels podcast wednesdays at
4 p.m eastern 3 p.m central watch live
on youtube on twitter and twitch
download on apple and spotify now here's
tony
[Music]
thanks for sticking with us through the
break
coming up here really soon
we're going to play the recording of the
interview
with brent henrich of washington's third
i just want to tell you one more time i
really thank you guys for all the
support you've given this year it really
means a lot it really really does
um you guys have given to the podcast
upgrade fund for the new microphone some
of the new software some of the new
equipment we're going to be making some
changes next year because of all that
stuff now we haven't reached our goal
yet
but i really everyone out there that is
not only given for buying merch um but
given financial support to the show
but more than that all the love you've
given not through tweets
likes shares
all that kind of stuff comments
uh all the great dm's that i've gotten
to keep encouraging us to keep going we
are going to keep going all the way
through 2022 we are not going to let up
we're going to keep pounding this drum
and i just wanted to take a special time
here
um to tell all you folks out there that
support the show
in whichever form and fashion that you
do it is highly appreciated
and it is all equal rather it's a simple
like on twitter or a 5 10 15 20 donation
to make sure that we keep everything
going with the equipment the software uh
the uploads
the production all that stuff cost money
and we really do appreciate it here at
the show um and keep watching keep
tuning in next year uh follow gabe uh on
on on twitter even though he's even
though he's not here today go follow
gabe it's at i am gabe sanchez
follow the podcast account on twitter at
tony michael's pod and at the tony
michaels keep tuning in to the [ __ ] list
roundup every single weekday noon
eastern 11 central
you know we surfed the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends i i started doing that
this year
just a year in in in
perspective here i started doing that
because i wanted to get more content out
i wanted to talk to you guys more about
what was going on on twitter i'm not the
greatest tweeter in the world where i
you know i i said this today i tweet and
i smash the tweet button i don't read it
i don't proof read it i really
unfortunately the [ __ ] thing is real
i don't give a [ __ ] if i get did you
know i'm trying to get my words out
right and i really i don't spend much
time proof reading something so and i
don't spend much time going and deleting
something
that i [ __ ] misspelled or you know
they're there or you're you're you know
whatever
all right i miss a period or a comma or
some [ __ ]
i really don't concern myself with that
and i don't think you should either i
think 2020 2022 should be the year of
pro-democracy
we have to pound that drum we have to
get a lot of things done
uh our coalition has to be tight and
strong to fight these fascists
like marjorie taylor green talking about
national divorce it is going to be
crucial
yeah we're going to have disagreements
and we do disagree we disagree on policy
and where and when and how
far
one of the most recent policies that
we're hashing out in our coalition is
canceling student debt
well guess how much student debt is
going to get cancelled if we have
national divorce the fourth reich
of the trump cult
how much debt how much student debt do
you think is going to be
is going to be canceled then huh
i'm telling you the most important thing
right now in 2022
since we're coming up in in a few days
is our democracy
that is the battle we must fight
now rather we fight it with a microphone
rather you fight it with donations
rather you fight it with a voice rather
you are running for office
or you are supporting a candidate by
knocking doors giving out signs making
phone calls text messaging
supporting them online
more importantly supporting them with
your wallet
it's gonna take it's gonna take a lot
it's gonna be a heavy lift because they
are trying to rig this game
they are trying their damnedest
now they're terrified
they're very scared they're projecting
it very hard especially when rand paul
is saying [ __ ] like he's saying and
marjorie taylor green is taking a step
further
for the fourth reich the national
divorce
and they're projecting it not only
projecting but they're saying it
outright that they wanna they wanna have
a coup inside the government they wanna
take over the house of representatives
and they wanna use that to get the
presidency which is not the design it's
delusional at best
but it's up to us to fight these to
fight this [ __ ]
you me your neighbors
people who are pro-democracy regardless
of where you stand on student debt
regardless of where you stand on the big
bird bill regardless where you stand on
voting rights we will have none of that
and i believe voting rights is one of
the main issues of keeping our democracy
but just lay down your arms because the
democrats can't get voting rights done
lay down your arms and see how much how
much voting rights you'll have in the
fourth reich the national divorce
just see so go support your candidates
in your districts
go find the candidate that you want to
support support them any way you can if
it's financially do that if it's if it's
with your time do that
it's very very very important and
crucial to our democracy and the most
important thing the most important thing
is go [ __ ] vote crawl over [ __ ]
hot lava
and i said it before and i'll say it
again i'm not just talking about marking
a name on a ballot
i'm talking about all the things that go
into democracy
register your neighbors talk to them
talk to your family members about voting
do the things that democracies do and
democracy will win that's what they're
scared of folks
they're scared of democracy they're
scared of majority rule
because
to the privileged
equality feels like oppression
and it's just a feeling they're
snowflakes
but it's important that we be
pro-democracy
so we're gonna play the the uh the
interview with brent here so stay tuned
right after the break brent's gonna be
with us i'm gonna be in a different
you guys know we record these things
but brent's gonna be right back with us
stay right there don't go anywhere
[Music]
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess
well now there's boycott binder the
ingenious organizer that keeps track of
everything and everyone you've ever
boycotted the 72 category filing system
makes it easy to organize boycotted
people places and things so you can find
them with ease the large centered area
can even fit your boycott sign but best
of all when you're done the boycott
binder folds right up so you can take it
anywhere so if you're tired of having a
cluttered mess call now and get the
boycott binder for just 29.99
plus you'll also receive our next rep as
a bonus just loop it around your neck to
travel with ease but call right now and
we'll double the offer that's two
boycott binders and two neck straps for
just 29.99
boycott binder is brought to you by the
same makers of binders full of women
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the tony michaels
podcast thanks for staying with us
through the break i have a special guest
for you today we unfortunately are not
playing trivia because we don't have
gabe here today because
we are recording this and we do have the
holiday season but i do have a very
special guest who wanted to have him on
the show for a while now and i'm so glad
to have him here he is the democratic
congressional candidate from
washington's third brent henrich brent
thanks for joining us
yeah
finally made it on the show we've been
talking about it for a while now haven't
we yes we have
i'm glad to have you i'm glad to have
you so so uh so tell me how it's how the
weather is up there on washington's
third right now well it's it's currently
the 23rd and it's actually pretty nice
outside but we're getting
unseasonable weather forecasted starting
on christmas day of nine days of snow
headed this way so
we'll see if the weather forecasters get
it right for once or not
nine
nine days of snow so i i live in
missouri and nine days of snow here that
would probably equal about i'd say maybe
you know
on on a in a good winter maybe like six
to nine inches how many inches is nine
days of snow where you're at
well if it comes as they project and
we've had recently it it could be 12 to
16 inches and that's that's ridiculous
for our area we're we're more set up for
ice storms we get really cold
air that comes from the east and then
the moisture comes off the pacific ocean
and everything freezes for a day you get
a quarter inch of glare ice
and then it melts away and and
everything's fine
so
we we still have the people freaking out
about snow
and i i do find it i grew up as a skier
going up to the mountains driving in
snow is fine
but it absolutely paralyzes our area so
right the idea so so the ice or the ice
doesn't paralyze you the snow does
because you know that you have the ice
though the para the ice paralyzes us but
only for like 36 hours and then it goes
away and then it's just back to rainy
and wet versus uh you know when the snow
comes and it's extended and everybody's
like it's normally like day four
people are like oh
i need milk and then everybody that has
spent all their time not getting behind
the wheel of the car
they get out they go to get milk and
toilet paper right and
and everything breaks loose
so
so so where is where is washington's
third district describe washington's
third district for us like okay there it
is
so
we are the southwest corner of the state
so we're the columbia river which
separates oregon from washington right
north to olympia which is our capital or
just south of olympia where our capital
is and we are the pacific ocean
all the way to the other side of the
cascade mountain range
so you guys you guys have a wide variety
and it's pretty it seems pretty diverse
then like uh as far as land goes you
know like yeah
we're 9 000 square miles wow of of this
district
and
we have
cattle ranching to the east we have uh
agriculture apples and standard uh you
know kind of so we have orchards we have
standard agriculture wheat and other you
know growing operations and then out at
the coast we have
shellfish farming with oyster farming
and crab fishing and then we have the
columbia river uh up and down which is
recreational commercial salmon fishing
so like we have and then we have a
densely populated area
where i'm located is vancouver
washington uh which is basically a
suburb of portland is the best way to
explain it um we're definitely our own
thing here but
in vancouver in clark county
is our densest population center but we
only make up about 55 to 60 percent
of the overall populous and so it's a
very diverse area and we have
people living and working right here
people living here commuting into oregon
for work we have you know it's it's
definitely a very very diverse district
well i think i think
that goes to show that it's probably not
easy to run
as a congressional candidate knowing
that you you know you have to appeal to
all these different diverse populations
right like not only do you have to
appeal to the rural cattle ranchers but
also um the the the people who are
farming for oysters and it sounds like
you gotta really because you're you said
it's 9 000 square miles that's like a
really large area that's a really large
area
some parts of the country know their
districts are so cut up and so small
that they're they're very small very
non-diverse districts but it sounds like
yours is pretty diverse oh we we have
that here in washington state i mean up
where premier j pal is from i i don't
know the square mileage on it but it's
right around king county downtown
seattle area and and the population
density to get the same population is
just this little blob on the map versus
you know right
nine thousand square miles yeah and uh i
i've made friends with anne-marie
danimes who's running in the fifth and
she has the entire eastern part of the
state from from canada to oregon from
idaho oh you know to right like 30
percent over of the state that's like
wow okay i thought i thought i had a big
district and right and it just goes to
show you that that politics isn't um
when you're
when you're when you're trying to get
the votes of the people it's it's not
about land mass it's about those people
so tell me tell me about the people in
the washington third tell me about the
people
well i mean we're we're uh definitely
like we're saying we're a diverse group
we have a lot of agriculture a lot of
rural area
uh
you know that
you know that makes up the area very
different uh
you know
makeup of the people compared to the
metro areas we're also blessed we have
the port of vancouver puerto va port of
longview
portland kelso uh
shahelis we we have
multiple ports here
so
you know we have import export going on
uh out of the different ports a lot of
very union uh based
economy here which i am very pro-union
i'm proud to say that since the day i
declared i have not printed one item
that does not have a union bug on it uh
to support you know through my candidacy
making sure that anything i'm doing is
supporting local uh you know family
living wage jobs through through union
work
and that's been a big theme of mine
uh but you know we're we're not the most
ethnically diverse district that is for
sure
but
how people live in different parts of
the district and how
the you know that all works is extremely
diverse right so so on one part of your
district uh the culture might be
different than on the other part even
though it's not as um you know diverse
as far as people of color
absolutely absolutely so so let's let's
talk about that because because of that
diversity i'm sure you get a an array of
diverse ideas on things like healthcare
climate crisis
abortion rights and some others so so
tell me about healthcare like what what
what is your platform and what do what
do you want to bring to the washington
third when you go to congress
for those folks uh in the washington
third on healthcare well my my largest
thing is i want to continue to push day
after day to get us to universal health
care where you go in you get treated and
you go home
but along those lines we have half a
million people in washington state that
do not have health insurance we do i
cannot find a legitimate number for how
many people are underinsured people that
have insurance plans that they're scared
to use because if they do
they're gonna still have a huge bill
that they can't you know possibly pay
uh i i
joke about my district being currently a
red district only because it's in a blue
state and
i guess i should use joke loosely
because i don't want to joke about
anybody here but at the same time we
currently have a health care plan in the
state that does 300 percent of federal
medicaid level
so we have a lot more people covered
than what other states would have
because our state has expanded upon
that
but i think one of the biggest things we
need to do is
add the expanded medicaid to other
states and i believe washington would
immediately jump on it and and move that
level up and get more people covered we
need to reduce the age to get onto
medicare
and keep
you know chipping away at things so that
we can get more and more people covered
with decent honest coverage
so that when they have an issue
they're they're able to seek you know
care for it
and that more people get preventative
care you know it's just you know an
ounce of prevention is worth of a pound
of cure it's
one of those things that people are
scared to use their insurance because
they technically have it but it doesn't
cover enough
well i i think you're right and i like
your messaging on that because i think
democrats fall into this gap where
you know they they use the wrong
messaging and you say words in there
like preventative care and things like
that but you just want decent health
care like most people in the country it
doesn't matter if you're on the right or
the left democrat or republican um and
probably you find this in your state
where you guys have 300
you know you said 300 of the
the the federal expansion or whatever it
is um that that
people just don't want to go bankrupt if
they have a medical bill or a medical
situation that is you know beyond their
control they they don't want it to
destroy their lives or their families
lives they want to be secure and i think
that's i think that's across the aisle
and i think sometimes democrats miss
that and they you know they get the
finger pointed and you know they say
things like i'm sure you get called this
commie socialist all this kind of crazy
stuff when this idea that you wouldn't
go bring bankrupt over health care it
really isn't socialist or communist
it's just it it's just like well we have
enough money in this country we
shouldn't let normal average people who
are hard-working uh go to work every day
haven't have a family and they work hard
for their family they shouldn't go
bankrupt or have the risk of going
bankrupt because of a medical situation
absolutely i i mean quick i'll keep it
as short as i can
my son has an asthma bronchial issue
and he will get all excited he's seven
years old he'll go crazy bouncing off
the walls and then he can't breathe
early on in the pandemic my wife ended
up having to take him to the hospital
for a nebulizing treatment because it's
life essential
she was there with him
and she hears from the next cubicle over
i mean because the intake areas in the
er aren't exactly you know sound proof
or as you know privacy as you'd want
and she hears a woman
in the next cubicle over being told
yeah well
it's 250 for your co-pay and the woman
starts crying she's like i don't have
two hundred and fifty dollars oh jesus
and the the lady from the billings like
well do you want us to send you a bill
and she's like well i don't have it now
so i guess you're gonna have to
and so
my wife goes beyond because she's dealt
with braden and their back getting braid
in his treatment and my wife comes home
and she starts talking to me and then
all of a sudden she's crying and i'm
like what and she starts telling me the
story and i'm like yeah it's hard and
then
my wife blurts out
they didn't tell her about the doctor's
bill that comes that was a 250
deductible for sitting in the er just
running just yeah just renting the space
inside the emergency room yeah not for
the doctor's care that's there or any
treatments that they provide
and i'm like
this is this is one of those things like
you know we have to to address and
that's when i decided to run and declare
and my wife and i were talking about i'm
like think of that woman that that right
had health insurance
she said she had no way to pay the 250
and had no idea that there was going to
be three other bills
coming
later for whatever treatment she
actually received that was just for
sitting in the cubicle and getting put
into a room
being allowed to see a doctor and that's
the that's the insane part about it
because we're just we were just talking
about going bankrupt and to a 250 copay
not the actual charge of the emergency
room
just the co-pay was so much that it was
going to strain um this family that your
wife had overheard it was going to
strain this family to a point to where
they they couldn't pay the 250 i think a
lot of people miss that
you know people work hard and they try
to do their best and they can't even
afford a 250 copay when they get sick
that that's going to put them out and i
think you know and
a lot of people who are afforded decent
healthier coverage through their work
um and maybe they have their their
entire career haven't really understood
what it's like
for some people
republican democrat right wing left
whatever it is
whatever it is whether you support joe
biden you support donald trump
people should not go bankrupt over a 250
dollar co and really there shouldn't be
a 250 dollar copay i guess that's the
point but the but they shouldn't go
bankrupt over a 250 copay when when
their kid is sick or they're sick
well the whole fact of the of the copay
is it's just a pay wall
right there
intentionally to discourage you from
using
the service that quote-unquote health
insurance right like it's it's like okay
oh darn my kid hit my car with a
basketball indented my door do i want to
claim that on my insurance or not
because oh it's a thousand dollar dent
and i'm going to pay 500 deductible and
then they're going to raise my rates do
i really want to do it that's why car
insurance has that garbage
but this is health insurance right these
are human beings
these are human [ __ ] bees
to just say no no do you really want to
get better like like is this really a
priority where you're gonna cut out
other things in order to afford
you know like that's
that's so i like that a word afford
because i guess that's the question i
would pose to someone who was in
congress if i met him in the hallway
right and we were talking about health
care i would say i would say to um to
future congressperson
brent
that brent my question is
can the united states afford to make
sure that that woman sitting next
to her
can they afford the 250 deductible so
they can get health care
and yes is the answer
yeah and and so we can afford it right
and that's that's the pathetic part
right and i think do you think that's
why republicans in this country are so
hell-bent on destroying the the i call
it the big bird bill because i hate the
messaging on billback better so i call
it the big bird bill but um
the build back better do you think
that's part of the reason why they do
not absolutely do not want that bill to
go through number one because of the
child tax credits which they've already
proven to this country that we can't
afford the the child tax credits uh it's
actually inflation protection because
we're trying to make sure that american
families are not
hindered by the inflation that we knew
was going to happen for the amount of
demand the pent up the demand that
happened during the pandemic and that is
go ongoing now um that we're going to
see through the holiday season and
hopefully through the spring that we
have this pent-up demand that's good for
the economy um but but that that child
tax credit was meant for inflation
protection
so
the american people know that they can
afford it right i mean like that
the sky hasn't fallen and like the
government hasn't collapsed and all this
you know crazy stuff that they said was
gonna happen right so none of that
happened
none of that happened so
what do you say what do you say to you
to your future republican colleagues
when they say we can't afford this we
can't afford this we can't afford to
give them i mean we can afford all the
military spending but we can't afford
this what would you say to your future
republican colleagues or maybe someone
like i don't know there's a guy named
joe manchin i'm just i'm just throwing
names out there i'm just throwing names
out there uh yeah yeah just just names
just names yeah right
nothing big
what i would say is we can't afford it
and and when you're running around
saying we can't
it's just because you don't want uh this
country has proven time and time again
that
when we want to do something we do it
it we say we can't when we don't want to
it's
it's the same as dealing with my
seven-year-old and
he gets halfway through a lego and one
time he's master builder and going
whatever and the other time it's i i
can't i something's wrong i can't
and i'm like no it's you won't you
you've lost interest in caring about it
and so
it's it's truly
it's first grade
politics it's
i say i can't because i won't because i
don't want to and that's all it is we we
can find solutions to these problems
when we choose to
so see do you think sometimes though
that it is the the the populace the
voters that that have this attitude
because i've been seeing this you know
again this goes back to really shitty
messaging um and and i know you're gonna
cause i agree with the messaging but i
don't agree how the message is being uh
the hashtag cancel student debt i
believe that's a horrible that's a
horrible way of messaging it um i
believe in i believe in the idea of of
making sure not to to
strap people down to the ground with
college debt and we should be able to
educate people but what happens in these
debates when we have this messaging
right like the college debt is you have
generations um that have already been to
college and paid off most of their
student debt they say well wait a second
i've already paid off all my that's not
fair you know it's
not fair and then you have people who
don't go to college who didn't who
didn't take on the debt and they say
well i don't have debt so you're gonna
give them their college but i don't get
the money to go to college now because
i've been punished because i chose not
to take the debt so there's a lot of
this um you know back and forth between
us and and i think that's partially
because of mentioning but do you think
that's a little bit um with the the
health care you know affordability and
and can the country afford it is well
you couldn't afford it for my generation
so we're not gonna afford it to your
generation do you think it's a little
bit of that more than it is the
politicians just like throwing up their
hands
oh it's it's definitely that you know
another big thing is you know i'm a
large union proponent but a lot of
unions are even pushing back on it
because
they worked hard and negotiated hard to
get that coverage and there's a feeling
of
oh we we fought and we sacrificed to get
good health care coverage and now you're
just gonna hand it away to everyone
um and that's one place unions and i
don't always agree there are certain
unions that are totally for universal
health care but there are other unions
that are just like
no we we don't we we that is a big thing
that you know why we fought for 28.50 an
hour instead of 33 an hour was for this
better health care so if everyone gets
health care and our people get health
care through that they're only at 28.50
instead of 33
and
and while i understand that's an
argument
i just don't believe it's an argument to
hold
others
from having health care
right so to hold the entire country
hostage from from having a type of
health care that wouldn't put you in
bankruptcy and having decent health care
coverage because to be honest i think
the unions are
should be given a lot of credit for
um you know not only uh the wages that
we have but also the health care now of
course now republicans have done
everything they can to actually get rid
of labor unions altogether um you know i
mean obviously for obvious reasons
because they don't want to pay a decent
wage and they don't want people have
decent health care and that's the one
thing i don't understand about people
who
we call them one issue voters but
they're more than one issue but they
vote against their own pocket um for
issues that these politicians really
don't believe in in the first place and
i'm sure we'll get into that here in a
minute but i do want to ask you about
one more issue on this because i think
healthcare comes out the student loan
thing comes out but the one thing i'm
interested in because especially in your
district it sounds like climate change
and
the climate crisis is a big deal because
you guys do have a lot of agriculture
and you have such a broad district of
that diversity of not only ranching but
farming and then you're on the coast so
tell me about how that plays into what
what you want to do
when you do take a seat in congress what
do you want to do about the climate
crisis not just for your state but for
the country
well well overall it's addressing the
climate crisis but at the same time it's
the the reasonable sensible things we
can do which is investing in green
energy and green energy production and
green energy transmission that is going
to slow things down as far as things
getting worse in the climate crisis that
are easy to do as far as starting to
install more more wind uh generation
solar generation uh installing large
facilities for batteries that will store
the sun's energy
when the sun goes down because there's
always always that ridiculous argument
or that we'll store the wind energy for
the day when it's not windy the wind
isn't going away but there are calm days
so yes we have to be able to produce
store and transmit that power and i
believe that that's step one we start
working on that we
we have
drastic issues from from the climate
crisis here right now we're not able to
hold on to our snow caps which is
causing drought in the summer but it's
also causing our streams to be warmer so
when the salmon return to spawn
the streams are too warm and are killing
off the salmon and their row
so they're not hatching and going back
out so we're having to do more hatchery
fish to try and supplement uh we
we had
116 degrees
in vancouver washington
all of western washington had a
three-day heat wave that broke every
single record where we ended up with
107 degrees i believe uh as the high
temperature all-time high never been
hotter here
the next day was 111 all-time high never
been hotter followed by a hundred and
sixteen
like
we shattered
by 10 degrees our all-time hottest
temperature
we have to do what we can
and if we can't just
create a carbon vacuum and i'm saying
that facetiously that you know we're not
going to be able to do that
we have to do other things we can we
have to replant forests
but immediately we need to stop making
it worse
and and that just means
burning less fossil fuels
and
oh you jumped back no no no no that's
okay
go ahead we in washington we don't burn
a lot of fossil fuel to generate our
energy we have wind and we have
hydroelectric dams
but we can generate more and the biggest
thing to me is i've told my kids my kids
are three seven and ten and i have told
them
geez i'd look into being an electrician
versus a lawyer because we're going to
have to rebuild the entire electrical
infrastructure of every house
every neighborhood and the overall grid
as we transfer off of fossil fuels
my street can't handle everybody going
out buying a tesla tomorrow
plugging in overnight and having that
load set to oh
optimum time to charge between 11 pm and
5 am
if all of those cars
instantly came on it would overwhelm all
the transformers in my area because it's
not set up for that kind of power draw
so
we need to look at the overall it'll
create jobs
and it'll transition us and we need to
look at
honest programs where i drive a 1997 bmw
m3 i love my car it was my dream car in
high school i was able to buy it about
eight years ago
i brought it back to life
i don't see the purpose to just smash it
and buy a new electric car
but when it
goes and it's going to it's got 200 000
miles on it it will be replaced by an
electric car right so we need to keep
the incentives there for people
and and we need to keep working on our
infrastructure creating those jobs where
when a gas powered vehicle goes away
we replace it with an electric
and so we keep working the plant so so i
i i think i think um you're making sense
there and i think
when you were talking about like your
street and and all that kind of stuff
because um you know there is a large
again diversity meaning like different
different parts of the country have
different electric grids we we watched
this with texas last year where their
entire state shut down because they have
this ridiculous notion of their electric
grid should be cut off from the rest of
the country which is kind of boneheaded
but i mean it is it is unfortunately for
some of the smart people in texas the
boneheads run the state unfortunately um
and they do things like that but i think
you know one part of the country it's
not going to be the same answer as
another part of the country right like
what you're saying with
we can't just crush all the gasoline
cars and have electric cars overnight so
we're going to have this diverse way of
doing things throughout the country and
i think that's the thing that creates
more jobs it creates more um
innovation
we have we have more
the dirty word of capitalism because
people are creating things and there's a
profit motive to to get somewhere
further and and and to to get a place
where well this this this plan may work
in this part of the country but here it
may work in another and you got to have
those innovative things like you were
talking about like what does the battery
storage look like right how how can that
be changed
uh you talked about a carbon vacuum i
don't know that there were we could be
out of the realm of a carbon vacuum who
says we can't who says we can't have
that um but if we don't invest in these
things if we don't
if we don't try in this country to make
sure that um there isn't just one type
of fuel one type of power um that that
we make sure we keep an open mind and
and we be innovative whether it be
i mean
again whether it be wind solar uh
battery uh electric cars um
you know hydro car whatever it may be if
if brent wants to invent the carbon
vacuum
by gosh we should we should do that so i
think the diversity there on climate
change is part of our answer to getting
ourselves because i don't i don't think
we're ever out of that mess do you like
we're we're too far past um
a climate crisis never being a thing
especially in my maybe my generation my
kids generation and possibly their kids
generation i think that climate crisis
is going to live with us for
for a while and i just don't see that
we're going to untangle all that all
this all the [ __ ] that we've done to
uh to put us in the situation that we're
in really fast i think that's the other
thing too is washington's not willing to
do the hard work
um to inch by inch by inch make sure
that the climate crisis doesn't get
worse right i mean maybe from what i
from what i've heard and all the
scientists
that i've heard speak on the issue is
we could shut off all fossil fuel
burning
today like right all cars stop you know
an emp to the world where we're we're
back to the stone ages so we crush your
crush your bmw is what yeah yeah but no
but like even my ring lights that are
making me look halfway decent in this
interview and using electricity to talk
to you like if that all went away
we still are going to continue getting
warmer for a period of time as the
amount of carbon
continuously you know and then it'll
peak and then it may start start
dropping and so are you saying are you
saying we're [ __ ] because i
no i'm saying i'm saying that that we
are if everything stopped today
next year will still be worse than this
year right
and how many years it keeps getting
worse until it starts to get better is
the question mark but the scientists are
saying we have to start doing more than
my incremental plan right because
we're not doing anywhere near enough and
brent's incremental approach probably
isn't going to fix it
i just believe that you've got to start
somewhere
well i think that's the challenge is is
that
we tried to start somewhere and the
administration that we had for four
years
uh decided not only not only to say well
we don't want to do that anymore we
actually want to take it in reverse um
we we want to we want to do the the bad
things that we know caused us to be in
this situation and we're in and we're we
want to go that direction
because it's easy profit right it's it's
hard profit to develop new innovations
and stuff uh the easy profit is to pump
the oil out of the ground and and and
you know
pumping into the back into the
atmosphere um you know like like like
we're doing
well yeah i mean uh on climate change on
all of this i drew the short straw a
couple months ago and uh amongst my
campaign team and i had to listen in to
our current representatives uh telephone
town hall where tell us about it yeah
and so at the very end she had like six
minutes left and she literally was
hemming and hawing if she was going to
take another question she said oh yeah
i'll take one more a person brought up
the temperatures in town that i had just
brought up
and she stumbled and fumbled for a
second and then she started talking
about the wildfires in the cascade
mountain ranges
and then said you do know fires are hot
though
and it's like well those are 60 miles to
100 miles away and i understand a
campfire does say wait wait a second
what are you saying was she blaming the
temperature on fires that were
oh my god so so let so i don't mean to
switch subjects here but that is very
interesting to me that someone who is a
sitting member of congress that's what
you're saying right this person is a
sitting member of congress says that
wildfires 60 miles away is causing the
temperature to change so
she just said you do know there's a lot
of fires burning and fires burn really
hot and she did not say that is the
reason it was hot in clark county she
just
she just said it and left it there
for anyone for anyone to eat right yeah
and and so i was like yeah but the fire
is because it's dry because it's hot and
as it burns it's putting more co2 in the
atmosphere rich is going to
right it's the short term the short term
the short term issue of the heat isn't
the fires burning it's the long term
issue that you're destroying the climate
weather is not climate and the heat off
the fire is not climate either yes
right well hey let's let's do this let's
let's talk about your current uh member
of congress and then maybe about some of
your opponents in this raid but let's
let's take a quick break and we'll be
right back
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
i've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever i try it never
sticks so when babel made a mag edition
i knew i had to give it a try babble
maggot edition makes it really easy to
learn and there's lots of lessons to
choose from like subtly racist to
full-blown white supremacists the first
lesson began with learning simple
phrases and soon i was putting those
words and phrases into a conversation
each lesson takes about 10 to 15 minutes
to complete and they're all really
different which keeps things interesting
the app is really smart it actually
keeps track of the words that i'm
struggling with i chose babble mag
edition because it's created by smart
white people like me and now i can't
wait to explore meet new friends and use
my new mega skills with my in-laws all
lives matter
[Music]
[ __ ] em
[ __ ] em [ __ ] up welcome
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for hanging in on the break
we were talking about
the current
congressional member
are they the current member of congress
in washington's third before we left for
the break
and this this person said that the the
heat from the fire is causing the
temperature to change in the climate to
change or you know not really saying it
but saying it without saying it
so let's
so i want to ask you about buying it
right exactly
uh so i want to i want to ask you about
the the current member of congress and
then also about the other candidates
that you're running in so let's start
with the the current member of congress
tell us their name and
and the situation that our current
member of commerce uh congress in
washington's third is jamie herrera
butler originally uh
uh won uh her election in 2010
so this is her sixth term
in congress uh she's self-proclaimed the
most conservative member of congress
uh she has she's stated uh directly on
the record that she has voted for every
single tax decrease that was in a bill
ever
no matter what was in the bill okay uh
she has never voted for any bill that
had any form of a tax increase
ever
no matter what was in the bill
doesn't matter what i guess that makes
her conservative right i guess that's
what makes her conservative is the tax
thing
yeah that's kind of funny because the uh
the root word of conservative is
conserve like you would keep it the same
that it is now not but you know whatever
so so so she's not running
right no she's running she's just oh
okay she's getting currently current
polling shows myself about a point and a
half ahead of her and then i'm trailing
currently behind a uh
full mega
supported donald trump endorsed bat
gates endorsed the whole list of who we
don't want to talk about endorsed uh
candidate joe kent
okay so so you and joe ken are out in
front of her is that yes is that right
okay so so why why is the sitting member
of congress behind you and joe kent
she voted for impeachment of donald
trump after the january sixth
insurrection and she was subpoenaed by
the
impeachment managers
to testify and she provided the written
testimony that she was in the office
with kevin mccarthy when he was talking
to trump saying that trump needed to
call every you know
you know stop this whole mess and
everything else on january 6th and
the maga crowd says she's a traitor so
let me ask so so what you're saying is
and i just want to make sure you're
clear we're clear on this because she
told the truth when the truth seemed
convenient
she is now no longer not not only not
only is she she's running but she
to the current numbers she cannot win in
her district because she told the truth
yes and uh joe kent has been endorsed by
every republican group in the area and
she's gotten censured by every
republican group in the area purely over
an impeachment the one the one decision
to cooperate with the church
yeah the one totally time the one time i
literally had to get on twitter and say
congratulations
thank you
jamie herrera butler for truly doing
what was right for southwest washington
and the whole nation
so in other words the the one possible
time that you possibly could agree with
this person is the reason why she is
losing
yes
so so let's let's dig into that just a
bit because that seems very interesting
to me because this goes to
um
the overall national strategy of the gqp
as i call them um these these maga
that they're trump cult it's a cult and
um and you can see it in your district
as we're unwinding this story here
where
someone like you called him kent right
is that that his name joe kent yeah
right he he's being endorsed uh by
donald trump and the rest of the trump
cult and that's what's putting him ahead
of the current member of congress who is
self-proclaimed
the most conservative
member of congress only because she
admitted to the truth
so
and we just seen this commercial about
manga babel and and trying to talk
you know we try to parody these things
on my show we try to use satire on my
show
to make fun of manga and to try to you
know uncouple it from maybe our culture
but at some point they're the parody in
of themselves and satire doesn't exist
anymore
so with this joe kent what makes is he
like any different than her
that and and he just didn't he just
didn't do what she did or what's the
difference why are they supporting him
and not her is it really because
sh trump can't stand to support her
because she's a traitor to trump
that's what it appears obviously i'm
keeping tabs on what my competition's
doing but i can't totally deep dive into
all of it but it really appears that
joe kent came out
and declared that he was going to run
for congress after
jaime's vote to impeach
and
he stated that on the record he moved to
this district to run against her because
she had done the unthinkable and had
voted to impeach
the president of her own party
their president their dear leader
whatever term you want to use for yeah i
use a lot of things the orange deity
mango mussolini jesus the cheeto dust
mobster grandpa poopy i got a lot of
nicknames for him yeah i got a lot of
nicknames for him but he really comes
across as dear leader to them like it
doesn't matter
what he says or or does
they they get behind him until today
which again we're recording this but the
candace owens you know interview this
morning right where he said no the
vaccines work
that he gets full credit for the
vaccines but that anybody going to the
hospital most likely isn't vaccinated
and that if you're vaccinated and
boosted as he is
that you know you if you do catch kovid
you know he didn't really say to take
precautions but he said you know it's
it's not that bad you know right is it
that bad of a case
okay so this morning you know a broken
clock is where is right twice a day
people say i say that his clock has been
running at like
at like 20 23 hours and 59 minutes and
it finally just hit that he was totally
right you know after how much time well
so so i actually i actually think he's
being pretty selfish in that interview
where he's trying to what he's trying to
do is reframe um the narrative because
the vaccine is working like it is
working it's clear it's working um it is
what will take us out of the pandemic as
soon as we we get our wits about us and
force these people to get vaccinated i
hate to say it like that but until until
we say look you cannot get on an
airplane you cannot you cannot have a
have a job you cannot be in the military
you can't get on public transportation
that you can't go inside these big
venues until we say that stuff and we do
what we've always done with vaccines
we've always done this always in history
we've done this
and it's worked
until we tell these people it is your
freedom to make the choice but if you
choose you are going to live with
consequences and these are the
consequences that you're going to have
until we get enough kahunes to look at
these people and do that um to get us
past that
i think we're we're going to continue to
have a little bit of the covet chaos
um but i think what he's doing is trying
to bank on this that that yes
history's gonna say that the that the
vaccine um took us out of this pandemic
and he said something that makes me
think this more than anything because he
said i
he said him
i came up with the vaccines like he
cooked it up in the oval office or
something isn't that crazy like like he
had some kind of science you know
experiment kit inside the bathroom of
the of the oval office where he's
and candace owens didn't know what to
say like literally
they did not have a conversation before
he sat down in front of her about what
she was gonna ask him like because she's
like trying to get him to move the
goalpost and he wouldn't and she's like
oh my god i thought you were gonna say
this but you're saying this like you can
see it written all over her face i can't
even believe they published it to be
honest with you
to jump back jump yeah two seconds so i
have this right here and yes that's me
that's all my information and it's all
publicly available anyways we've never
had to have those in the past they knew
that this was politicized right from day
one
to where people like oh you can't
require vaccine passports the only
reason we're carrying these dumb cards
is because people knew at the beginning
the way it was handled from day one
that this became political right it's
health care it's public health it's
never been this way people got polio
vaccines they didn't carry cards
you know i don't have a card that says i
have my measles mumps and rubella
booster or or my tetanus or like it's in
my medical chart if i go in they can
pull it up they ask it's probably it's
probably in your school records because
it was required for your school records
yes but i'm saying but we never carried
it around on our person
because it's never been political it was
never it's oh have you been you know are
you up to date and people just honestly
answered
and it was always like okay well you can
go to school for a week or two have your
parents get your doctor's appointment
and right get get caught and they would
yeah they would it just was done
well and and you know that's um
that goes to some of this q anon maga uh
misinformation and some of the [ __ ] that
that uh like can people like candace
owens who she she's vaccinated by the
way uh 100 she's vaccinated probably has
her booster there's pictures of her at
madison square garden which you actually
have to have that little card that you
showed
she would have to have that card to get
into madison square garden i think she
went for a ufc fight or something and
someone else took a picture with her and
got it posted on instagram and showed
her inside madison square garden so you
know she's vaccinated and they run
around talking about oh well it's more
about the freedom and the choice and
trump said that in that interview which
is all [ __ ] because they do have the
freedom they do have the choice but you
don't you don't have the freedom from
consequences of your choices and this
actually leads me to the my body my
choice thing because i want to ask you
about abortion rights
um and i want to ask you about sb 8 and
the supreme court but this goes to this
notion that and it really pisses me off
when they use that because to think that
a a woman a pregnant person who decides
that they rather
for their own health
or for whatever reason need to terminate
a pregnancy and have an abortion that
there's no consequences to that
it really it really pisses me off to
think that when someone who is
pro-choice who has for decades and
decades had the
the phrase my body my choice to defend
their liberty to choose
to choose about their body and their
uterus to actually believe that there
shouldn't be any consequences or that
there is no consequences
diminishes that choice diminishes our
rights and diminishes our liberties when
we have freedoms and rights and
liberties there are consequences for
those things um as much as we have to
fight for every inch for those liberties
we have the consequence and when you
choose when you choose not to get
vaccinated and make your your community
unsafe there might be consequences to
that but it brings me to the my body uh
my body my choice and abortion rights um
because we see the supreme court
barreling towards
overturning roe v wade now i don't think
they're going to use the sba law the
texas law
as as their mechanism i i believe the
the mississippi case that they have
um really gives them the ability to do
what they want to do
because it's obvious the court wants to
overturn roe v wade so tell me tell me
when when when you make it into congress
and tell us for your not just for your
constituents but also the country
because i know it's a national
conversation
that we're gonna have about roe v wade
and the overturning and abortion rights
and people's liberty of their own bodies
tell me about what your stance is and
tell me what you're going to do in
congress to fight for those liberties
i want to pass legislation
that regulates abortion to the point of
where
there is a facility available to anyone
that needs it that is professionally
staffed that is warm that is well lit
that is full of any information someone
can need
we're a person
with a uterus and i say that because
there are
trans men out there that have uteruses
there's women there's there's all of
this
but
to allow a person to go seek the care
that they need
and have them get that care
and that's the end
that
what happens between a person
and their doctor and what their doctor
feels is necessary acceptable
that is between
those people
i have been in a situation where my wife
was pregnant
she had a placental abruption
she had five weeks of bleeding
uh at 20 weeks
she went into labor
rushed to the to the hospital they gave
her an epidural all of her contractions
stopped
um
they were giving her blood
trying to figure out what we were gonna
do whether she was gonna live in the
hospital for another seven weeks
till uh we were able to
you know have the baby
birth
the middle of everything my wife started
having another massive bleed my wife was
without full consciousness would be the
best way to explain it
the doctor looked at me and said brick
you have to make a choice you can meet
your daughter and
your wife will be here and and you'll
meet her and and she will pass away or
you can cross your fingers and hope and
your wife and your daughter will die
and i said push the pitocin
and so we met our daughter
uh addison and held her
and
she's with us to this day on our mantle
uh
and
it really formed that whole thing of
we needed access to care there
and i look at bills like sbh and some of
these others
that would restrict my wife's ability to
be alive now
because oh we should have hoped or oh
it was 20 weeks and so
you aborted or you
you killed or you murdered or you you
know feticided i've had all of that
thrown at me
and and i let it roll off
but the only thing we should be
regulating is that it's healthcare
people have a right to health care and
have a right to have that health care in
a correct environment and to me that's
a warm
professionally staffed facility
that
doesn't come with caveats
so in other words you don't want to
politicize the people's choices between
their doctor and themselves
no
and i i think um i i appreciate you
sharing that story um i actually did not
know that and um
i
i think everyone
you know discounts these tough decisions
to make when it comes to
a situation like you guys were dealing
with and they don't you don't know what
you would do you don't know what you
would say
and to
to to tie someone's hands like you're
saying
um by forcing the government
which you think these
big government you know they always talk
about big government but get government
out of my life you think they would want
it out of that particular choice in
their life
um and they you know they
again the my body my choice of the
vaccine it is your body your choice make
your choice
with the consequences just like you had
a choice to make right
and i live with it every day right and i
see her on the mantel every day but i
see my wife every morning as well so
there's consequence to it um but one of
the positives was my wife is still here
and we've had two more amazing kids
since that day
and that's a
a fantastic thing that you guys have
been able to have a family and be a
family and yes there are consequences
and
you know hindsight's always 20 20 on a
decision like that um we didn't have
that situation
in in um
where my wife had trouble with the
pregnancy we actually
my wife wanted to have her iud removed
so we could
have a baby
and um at the time because of situations
it was easiest for her to go to a
planned parenthood to have them remove
the iud
and when she went to the the planned
parenthood now this is the the craziest
part remember we are she's going to the
planned parenthood to have her iud
removed so we can have a baby right
this is not the this is not the other
way around like they want to sell it all
the time she's planning right to enter
parenthood right well we were wanting to
have our second child right
she had an id she had had an iud for a
while our our our oldest child was
getting older and we were like well we
don't want this amount of
you know distance between them
but she went to the planned parenthood
she scheduled um an appointment and when
she pulled in like they have a fence
around this planned parenthood and there
was there was a
a security person that would come out
and meet them at the car and escort them
in because there were the crazies on the
street yelling and screaming and you
know throwing things
whatever they do right
um threatening people and
they were doing that to my wife but she
was going in for the reason that they're
fighting for does that make sense like
the planned parenthood wasn't doing the
thing that you're yelling and screaming
to hold your signs about they were doing
the thing that is pro life i guess if
you call it that right like they were
they were removing an iud a medical
device that my wife decided to have in
her body it was her decision it was our
like you said planning a parenthood
kind of kind of funny how those words
work right
and and she was going to choose to be a
parent again to try to get pregnant now
um the historians we did have a
beautiful daughter and and it did take
us a while after she
went and had her iud removed at planned
parenthood to actually have to to get
pregnant it took a little bit you know
there's these these things that that i
don't understand i'm not a doctor i i
don't know anything about medical and i
i really don't understand pregnancy
really honestly that's why i try to keep
my opinion out of it like
like like i'm a man i definitely and i i
don't have a uterus i can't have a baby
i should not be telling other people
with uterus is what they can and cannot
do with him that's my view of it so i
really do appreciate your story i know
that's probably
it's because i think everyone might have
a story like that but um to hear that
you guys had
the moments with your child um is is
heartwarming but it's also heartbreaking
to know that you had to make those
decisions that you had to make and that
you guys have to think about that every
day um but it is very very heartwarming
that you guys got to spend that little
bit of time
the one thing i i want to add is
that
people when i talk about it they like to
say to me
oh but you're an exception you and your
wife are an exception oh that's an
exception oh that should be written down
as an exception i'm like it doesn't
matter where you draw the line in the
sand right there's somebody standing on
the other side where you say that's the
exception
but why isn't the person standing next
to them and if there's an exception over
there we have to move the line right we
don't need exceptions
and that's where you end up where you
can't put in my view you can't put a
line it comes down to medical
decisions between
a a physician
primary care ob you know i'm not trying
to knock anybody down a peg
paratologists or whatnot but as far as
that's between a person and medical care
right
and leave it to that their body their
choice right yep
the actual the actual your body your
choice and and actually um having those
consequences that you have to live with
now
i i believe it's interesting what you
say about the exceptions because
i've actually
um watched the
because i've been pro-choice
as long as i've known what pro-choice
and pro-life was right when i when i was
faced with the decision and i was a
teenager when this happened because i
was i grew up catholic in the catholic
church and this came up in our
confirmation but when i was posed with
the question pro-life pro-choice and i
discovered what they were i was like
well yeah i'm for the woman right i mean
like she gets to make her choice um of
course back then there wasn't all this
you know um
um
different stuff like we have in the sba
law
because i believe that the the
the pro-life movement which they're not
pro-life is my opinion but the pro-life
movement
never really
went after the target of the woman
themselves right they always tried to
make it about um
planned parenthood's the enemy the
doctors are the enemy the the government
is the enemy but with the sba law they
really are targeting
the pregnant person right the person who
is making that choice it's not it's no
longer oh well the the planned
parenthood's trying to brainwash people
or the government's trying to get people
to get abortions or they're trying to
push abortion or whatever their
narrative was you know they they always
near now they are targeting the pregnant
person themselves with this sba
vigilante type law is that the way you
see it um and and how do you combat
that and and what do you do in congress
when you get there to try to make sure
roe v wade is codified so we don't have
this nonsense well there's multiple
bills already that have been proposed
that i would want to to you know
co-sponsor um you know there's other
things that that i would like to see
uh out there that other people haven't
said as far as just like i want to
legislate that everybody has access um
people want to say oh everybody should
have or that you know but i just think
everyone
that it needs to be treated as a health
condition and that all health conditions
are covered under universal health care
so that's a long road fight but the the
protections granted by roe
need to be codified into law and they
need to be codified into law yesterday
so a lot of things that i'm running for
i really hope get taken care of and get
taken off my talking point list and
push down to the yeah i'm gonna have to
play
defense on that to make sure it remains
uh and and that's a hard position for
somebody that's running to to be running
saying i want this but they may get it
done and then i may be getting elected
primarily to defend
that
and i don't mean that in an
obstructionist way
where
what we deal with with the gop and the
gqp
is they just want to be obstructionist
to obstruct but there's many things that
have happened so far this year and if we
can get build back better through
and and some of these other things
that it may become the democrats job
to play a lot more defense to make sure
that these things survive
and and that's i just believe going to
be a big part of things
i i think you're absolutely right on on
the defense part of it um i don't know i
don't know if
is the word that i want to use is as far
as the voting rights and making sure
that we're pro-democracy because i don't
actually have a problem with uh
republicans having an opinion
and wanting to try to push legislation
as long as it's done in a pro-democracy
manner not an authoritarian manner um
like what we have with the gqp now i
think that's the problem that we have in
the country is that minority is ruling
um and that
you know with this gqp this crazy manga
q anon trump cult because i know i know
you probably want to talk about um
one of the candidates that you're
running against not the current member
of congress but the other person that's
ahead in the polls um that is running
neck and neck with you you probably want
to talk about that person than some of
their views because it seems like it's
it joe kent right and that is yeah yeah
joe can it seems like
not only is he supported by the q anon
america first maga q anon timothy matrum
pumping cult
but
uh he embodies it right joe kent is 100
on board with this matt gates idea
to literally
uh put donald trump in a speaker and
then try and find a way to impeach and
remove
joe and kamala at the same time
to quote install donald trump
back as the president
it's absolutely ludicrous it's
undemocratic it's against everything
but
they truly believe this or at least keep
saying it so that people believe they
believe it
and and he's 100 percent on board with
it and i'm just like how can that be a
thing we don't install
presidents in this country we don't need
to install so so this is this is coming
from
um
steve bannon's trader tv that's what i
call it steve bannon's trainer tv he
calls it something different but i i
don't give a [ __ ] what he calls it it's
trader tv uh because steve bannon has
been pushing this issue for months and
months and months where they're they're
going to take the house um he even said
the other day on his program he said
that they're going to overturn county
clerks and and what he's by overturning
county clerks is he said the words he
wants to take over the election
apparatus which
that kind of goes into the voting rights
um
realm right so in this country we
actually don't have a federal voting
system now we do but we we really don't
we have a local voting system
um that that is that happens that's why
you're running for a local district
you're not you're not running i mean it
is a federal district for congress but
your
the county controls the election um your
state controls the counties how they do
you know they control the election laws
and and the federal government has
oversight of that and i i believe that's
how we should have it but we should have
a little more um federal oversight in
the in the way of democracy because we
are one i don't know i'm just you know
putting that out there that maybe the
federal government should have the
ability to make sure that states aren't
doing like what george is doing where
they want to like your words to install
um uh a republican
in some of these districts so but what
you're saying is joe kent wants to go on
board with this steve bannon trader tv
uh hair brain scheme because i actually
believe that it's completely delusional
like
number one they would not only have to
they would not only have to uh impeach
and remove
joe biden and kamala harris at the exact
same time for for the speaker to become
the president which in their minds they
want donald trump to be speaker right
is that what he's saying
yeah yeah they're saying to that they'll
they'll they'll elect trump as speaker
than have trump no but joking isn't good
is running on this he's saying this okay
so so i actually believe that um
that they're positioning themselves and
this is just my feeling on watching what
they're saying and the language that
they're using especially seeing what
trump's saying about vaccines seeing
what legal trouble he's going to be in i
think they're waiting those waters
because they want to keep him as this
messiah type person but it doesn't
necessarily mean he has to be the one in
power right there's a lot of struggle i
don't know if you notice like linwood
and mike flynn and roger stone alex
they're all fighting it's all in fights
steve bannon
it's all in fights to who is going to be
the king maker here and i believe that
if if republicans like joe kent like
you're your opponent
uh in this race and and i want to ask
you about uh
how that works uh when we talk about top
two
um uh the type elections but uh here in
just a minute but if if joe kent were to
become seated as a member of congress
and enough of them are seated as members
of congress to actually build a caucus
around this idea i actually don't
believe they'll make trump the speaker i
believe they'll make someone like steve
bannon or mike flynn or roger stone
or matt gatz or marjorie taylor green
the speaker of the house or even joe ken
the speaker of the house and i think
that's actually the big risk that we run
here um
because i don't i i think trump has too
big of an ego to be the speaker of the
house what do you think
yeah i i don't know i've heard you know
all the crazy talk and i've heard joe
spewing the crazy talk and say things
and then and then
take three steps back and say if trump
would agree right
right
like oh i can't guarantee we're gonna
get him as speaker because because trump
has to go along with that but that's the
plan but yeah that's the plan but i've
heard matt gates say that oh wouldn't
marjorie taylor green or louis gomer or
paul gosar make a great speaker and i'm
like
absolutely not
wouldn't they wouldn't make a good uh a
good cart pusher at the local grocery
store for crying out loud i said spent
three years yelling at my computer and
yelling at my friends that kept trying
to get rid of trump and i'm like he
still doesn't know what's going on
mike pence understands how this crap
works right getting rid of trump could
be really bad if you know like like
when you get somebody that actually
understands how to to run legislation
through and everything else
and so it's
to the idea of marjorie taylor green or
or
lauren bober or or louie gilbert like
going up there and asking if we can move
the moon
uh to fix climate change it's like
okay
this is gonna be a total joke
but we're not gonna do necessarily
long-term damage because
no one's going to say we should impeach
our way
into putting any of those three in the
white house like even the crazies well
but but don't you think i mean we we
we're we're talking about this as if it
could happen which i mean in all reality
if they got control and they had total
control they would try it i i don't know
if it would work but they definitely
would try it
and that's the thing that needs to worry
us is that they want to try it they will
try it they will do it it's it's clear
that they are okay with committing coups
um they tried on january 6th they are
trying now this is their coup attempt i
believe that this is their coup plan is
to take over the government inside the
government they're gonna they want to
use the house of representatives to take
over the government and destroy our
democracy now i actually believe
that um they think
and and they i mean they use like joe
kent uses trump as a high pedestal to
get the people riled up at maybe the
meetings and make make them think that
he's going to install trump as dictator
which is what he's saying
but i actually think what what is more
dangerous than trump being installed is
like a steve bannon because to your
point of
that mike pence knew all the apparatus i
think steve bannon is three times as
smart as donald trump and he's four
times his evil like he he is um he is he
is just trying to destroy our democracy
and he he is he is gathering up an army
and in his words the the shock troops to
destroy our democracy that is his goal
and um i believe joe kent is probably
one of those shock troops he see he
views him as
a pawn and a tool in his plan uh to take
over democracy and destroy it
joe kent was on bannon this morning for
like the like the 20th or 30th time
since he's been a candidate like like
yeah
joe kent and bannon are are peas and
carrots right well and and i'm i'm sure
that's where a lot of his money is
coming from is the griff the ban and
trump grift um and joe probably likes to
he probably likes it that way the stuff
is campaign coffers full of of uh
delusional money um uh
um you know trader tv cash i guess you'd
call it that's probably why he goes on
uh steve bannon's
tv show
yeah but it's but it's a strategy and
it's working as far as uh you know he's
raising over a million he's raised as of
uh end of oct or end of september the
october 15th filing he had raised 1.1
million dollars to buy 26 000. so so
let's do this tell me tell me um
because we're we're running low on time
here and i want to ask you about the
legos behind you but um so tell us
before we talk about the legos tell us
where we can find your stuff where we
can if they if if the audience out there
wants to support you tell us give us a
shameless plug tell us shameless plug uh
at b henrich on twitter and then you can
easily scroll and find the the million
times i've shamelessly asked for for
money but uh my website is technically
brenthenrich.com
but we made a shortened one it's bh the
number four c
dot com
and that'll redirect you so you don't
actually have to know how to spell
enrich uh because we found that that was
a problem so so campaign manager came up
with bh the number 4c.com and and takes
you right there there's donate links
there's it you know covers the my main
issues uh how to get a hold of us
uh 10
every 10 people that look at my website
eight say it's great to say it's the
worst thing ever so the least
constructive comments i always get is
it's great or it's terrible
it is what it is now we're elbow deep in
a campaign and and trying to go forward
but uh we keep adding to it to to give
more information uh as things go along
but very active on twitter i am on
facebook and on instagram with a very
low
uh amount of people uh following me
there but definitely want to grow that
audience
so if you'd like that's a
b henrich the number four wa
uh so b henrich four wah
is uh where you can find me over there
and yeah that's that's my shameless plug
is uh please go to my website click on
donate and uh and donate
because we got to beat joe kent up there
right i mean that that's the thing we
got we got to beat the steve bannon and
washington's third because that's what
he is is joking is steve bannon in
washington's third and i appreciate you
coming on show but before we go i want
to ask you because it looks like you
have you have this uh little thing about
legos because you got some legos tell us
about the legos in the background there
well well right now
we have the
this finger we have the lego nintendo
entertainment system okay so that's all
legos
that's all legos that is
literally
oh okay that is all legos
and it yeah and it actually will
go inside oh looky there
and it will actually load down like a
nintendo entertainment system
so that is
that is that one and then uh i just
recently got the cat d11 for uh you know
we're going into the infrastructure
bills gonna start spending money here
we're gonna right make a new road so i
thought that would be a fun one and uh
lego flowers that that never die and
i've just been into lego been into legos
since i was a child my kids are into
them
and so i literally there's
i have many many scars on my feet uh
from from stepping on legos in my
bedroom when i was a kid i grew up in a
farmhouse with hardwood floors and i
would i would always have i would always
have legos out in my bedroom
and um on the hardwood floor so i have
many scars on my feet from where i uh i
stepped on legos now i don't i never did
um
i never did it near what you have there
i was always
building little houses or cars or trucks
or something like that but but um i'm
obsessed
our downstairs playroom we call it the
lego room
last time i took a real guesstimate at
it we had just over a half a million
bricks oh my gosh
i got a couple i got a couple buckets
from when i was a kid but no near i have
a million no no no
it's so what's your what's your favorite
lego series like is there a favorite one
that's like um you know my favorite one
when i was a kid was like the cowboy um
you know the western
you know that that was one of my
favorite
i i have to think back to the original
blue and gray lego space and if you
think of lego movie and benny and his
spaceship like like all of that 1980s
space stuff like that and then they went
into to blacktron uh
as an expansion of of lego space and and
that truly has the biggest pull to my
heart but
all the newer stuff they have come up
with some crazy complex you know like
right i mean that thing's bluetooth
operated entirely motorized
it drives the scraper goes down the
blade goes up and down there's a loading
ladder on the other side that folds down
for where the operator would get so so
the technic stuff is like
that one was a challenge and literally
took so how long does it take you to
build oh five days
five days and it was like 4 000 pieces
oh wow but that one was like
2500 pieces
but my son put it together because he
got to it before i did and he's seven
years old and he put it together in a
day and a half you know so like some of
them you know but it's just it's a fun
thing to do and a fun thing to collect
and and since everything's happening on
zoom i change my backgrounds out you
know oh wait where am i uh you know
about once a month so that if i come
back on the tony michael's pod next year
we'll talk about new legos yeah it's not
gonna have the d11 or the nintendo it'll
have mos eisley space port or the
millennium falcon will be sitting back
there oh okay well i'll look forward to
the millennial falcon i like that so so
it sounds like you have like a display
case downstairs where all these things
reside that you ship them in and out yes
yes or they get taken apart and re-put
back together for the fun and the
challenge so oh okay okay so so you so
you don't just put them together and
leave them sometimes you take them back
apart and see that was the thing i was
my legos were like mutant legos that i
didn't like buy one kit like i had
cousins they didn't want their legos
anymore so i had those and then my mom
would find some at a garage sale and you
know it's never like one kit i just like
had mutant legos and i would buy the
small little things with all the people
in them and like
the swords and the guns and the hats and
the clothes and you know and i i so i
had mutant legos you know i had spacemen
and cowboys all on the same
you know on the same board so oh we all
did that's that's the funny thing about
my son like you get him a new lego set
which there's multiple underneath our
christmas tree that he had whatever
he'll build it but once it gets broken
it never becomes that again and then
he'll go and we'll sort them all out and
then he'll bring up something and it's
this giant yellow cube
and it's either a submarine or a
spaceship or whatever and i'm like it's
all yellow he's like yeah
yeah i got the yellow bin out like it's
like
one week it's a red thing one week it's
a blue thing yeah like like but it's
like you know you can mix at your colors
but then you have to get out yeah right
well and then you'd have to separate
them out when he takes them apart
so this is just you just swipe it into
the bend and you're good to go
exactly
well i really do appreciate you joining
us brent uh please come back um you know
we've been doing some pop-ins on my live
stream i don't know if you watched the
live stream but maybe maybe 180 days
we'll we'll have you pop in on the live
stream or something i i really
appreciate you joining us uh keep keep
fighting out there i know you're
pro-democracy i know uh every everyone
says that brent on twitter is genuine
and he really wants to fight for our
democracy
um and that's why he's running so i
appreciate having you on the show yeah i
i please if anybody send me a dm or or
comment on anything i post i do my best
to personally get back to to everyone to
to respond to every question so you hear
that fill up his dms that's what he's
saying
fill up those dms thanks a lot brent
thanks a lot
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
troubleshooting and support are the keys
to good business
that's why at a t we are dedicated to
offering superior service to all of our
customers
whoever you are we are here to help my
internet is not working okay we're gonna
walk through some steps right now first
i want you to restart your router and
see if that changes anything starting
today we are proud to announce that att
will be offering our new troubleshooting
feature for customers with a different
point of view we call it echo every
conservative has opinions my [ __ ]
internet is down again did someone in
your neighborhood get the vaccine
because that can destroy your router you
know what my neighbor's whole family
just got the faucet at a t we know every
customer is unique and requires
different approaches none of my direct
tv channels are working how am i
supposed to watch joe rogan commentate
the ufc fight i've been told by higher
ups there's a deep state hack and that
is what's causing your outage
soros no matter the issue or how
conspiratorial it is we'll tell you
exactly what you want to hear
and we believe in it so much that we've
decided to fund ninety percent of this
new feature echo by at t
[Music]
the tony michaels podcast wednesdays at
4 p.m eastern 3 p.m central watch live
on youtube on twitter and twitch
download on apple and spotify now here's
tony
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for hanging in with us with the
interview what a fantastic interview
brent henrich
of washington's third
the democratic candidate
over there
he plans he plans on beating
um not just one republicans but a couple
so ghost go follow brent on all the
socials you heard him at the very end
he'll answer any of your questions in
the dm so
yeah it really honestly give him give
him a shout out uh send him send him a
dm if you do have a question especially
if you're in washington's third
but not not only seek out brent but find
find the uh candidates in your local
district support those candidates rather
that be financial
like shares getting helping them on
social media get the word out at town
halls go participate in those
conversations if they're virtual town
halls or actual town halls
vote for those people uh help canvas for
those people
and when your candidate doesn't win the
primary and another pro-democracy
candidate chip in for that candidate we
have to we have to fight for all the
pro-democracy candidates out there all
of them uh not not just the one in your
district but the one in every single
district it is crucial to our democracy
that is the battle that we are in is for
democracy
thank you thank you thank you for
joining us here on the tony michaels
podcast don't forget
every single weekday noon eastern 11
central we do the [ __ ] list roundup on
twitter and twitch so join us tomorrow
and friday we are not going to take a
day off for the new year's holiday
we will be back on monday we're also
this week and we're also going to do a
special year in bonehead of the week if
you want to go vote for bonehead of the
week go at the tony michael's pod
the poll is over there
there's a few names you'll recognize on
that poll at tony michael's pod the poll
is over there or you can follow me at
the johnny michaels you find the poll
there as well
go go subscribe to the youtube channel
you'll catch all the bonehead of the
weeks
the podcast all
the shitless roundups that we do every
single week and again
this is the last podcast of the year and
i want to thank everyone again for all
your support rather it is
sharing the the tweety tweets that i so
recklessly uh with abandon put out
um sharing the podcasts coming listening
giving comments
uh subscribing to the channel
buying merch
and also
uh contributing to the podcast upgrade
fund which you can find at the
tonymichaels.com
you can find all those links there to
all the channels all the places that the
podcast is
the merch store for the [ __ ] hats
and you can find the podcast upgrade fun
there i want to thank everyone
everyone
thank you thank you very much it's been
a great year now we're not finished yet
because we got a few more [ __ ] lists
around it but this is the last podcast
of the year
thank you thank you so much for 2021.
i'm looking forward
i'm looking forward to kicking ass with
you in 2022
so before i go
[ __ ] them
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking